Entertainment Tonight
Kirsty
Ally
cheers
Look Who's Talking
you seriously so uh this is the ET
headquarters in New York as you can see
it looks like hell it is nothing looks
like this anymore hello 1984 gone bad in
1984. oh Kirstie Alley look look who
works here Kirstie Alley this person
does nothing
this is my lunch thing crew number one
doing nothing crew number one doing
nothing is this a real business
Entertainment Tonight
uh-huh
really
what did he do
it doesn't surprise me I'm sorry baby
it'll never happen again anyway this is
a dressing room here at
the ET in La is so much better than this
but don't tell anyone
I'm busy what is it hello
hello
are you
are you calling me
you're not supposed to chew gum I've
told you that like 50 times
I mean I'm just doing it's not like I
work here I'm doing this as a favor
head of CBS oh oh oh oh
nice over here that are working in your
desk next to me and they're chewing gum
and they have snacks on the table
they're not working very hard it's
Entertainment Tonight
uh-oh somebody's on speaker how's this
somebody in this office is calling me
Gan why don't you just walk over here
I'm two feet away from you you don't
need to call me
I see why you don't get anything done
and I see why nothing good comes out of
New York
the LA office wouldn't operate like this
[Music]